hey guys it's Justine and today we are
checking out the brand new tone free T90
earbuds from LG now I am really excited
about these because they are actually
the world's first earbuds with Dolby
Atmos and Dolby head tracking they have
Bluetooth 5.3 active noise cancellation
up to 29 hours of battery life with the
included charging case and they're also
super comfortable to wear thank you so
much to LG for partnering with me on
this video and sending me these to check
out so let's unbox and get into it
[Music]
two USB cables I like that these are
really thin cables we have a USBC to a
3.5 millimeter headphone jack and we've
also got a USBC to a usba I do like that
the cables are color coordinated so if
you do get the white you'll have white
cables and if you get the black you'll
have the black cables they also have
some different size ear tips so
depending upon your ear size they have
some different options for you also
color coordinated look how pretty I love
this case it's a nice feel small super
light
[Music]
all right let's put them in let's try
them out shall we
oh
look at this
so I would say right off the bat these
are super comfy I mean if you watch any
of my videos then you guys know that
sometimes my ears do not get along very
well with in-ear headphones like these
are super comfortable like I feel like I
can go for a run I can take calls I can
play video games I could be raging
with my gaming consoles look at this the
head shake test
holy
why are they staying in I don't know
like I'm I'm so surprised like I'm so
surprised these are staying in my ears
and I'm so excited about it but these
ear tips are a little bit different
they're actually made of like a medical
gel and they just sort of conform to my
ears and it's not like there's a lot of
pressure or anything it just they just
fit you can also actually test out how
well they fit in your ears using the
tone free app so we're definitely gonna
try that out and see what it says now I
have these all synced to the tone free
app with Bluetooth and here's our little
user manual so this shows you the
different touch controls touch once to
play and stop touch twice to end call
and also volume control touch three
times to play the next song and the long
press will turn your ambient mode and
noise cancellation on and off test my
best fit in the ears we go let's start
oh it's telling me to try a different
Ear Gel okay
I'll pop on some smaller ones and see if
that helps oh that actually already
feels better wow okay thanks for the hot
tip and then if we scroll down we have
some equalizer settings so you can do
immersive natural bass boost treble
boost 3D sound stage and this is where
we have the Dolby head tracking and
virtual sound we're definitely turning
that one on all right let's listen to
some music I'm gonna listen to some
OneRepublic but you guys are going to be
hearing some royalty-free music oh this
is nice
okay
oh yeah
the base just hit in all right let's
test out the noise cancellation
okay
noise cancellation is on
[Music]
were you talking to me
I didn't hear a single thing you said
all right well I guess active noise
cancellation works
check one thing I really like about
these is the plug and Wireless feature
so you can already connect these to
basically any device over Bluetooth but
what if you want to connect a device
that doesn't have Bluetooth like maybe
you're at the gym or on a plane all you
have to do is connect the charging case
to the device with the included cable
and then you can connect wirelessly to
the case plus sometimes devices do have
Bluetooth but it doesn't always work
that well this is so perfect for those
scenarios let's see if it worked oh my
gosh it's working
[Music]
oh man this is awesome because sometimes
I have trouble connecting Bluetooth
headphones to this and now here we go
problem solved so let's talk about
Bluetooth and sound quality these are
rocking the Qualcomm aptx Bluetooth 5.3
as well as Snapdragon sound supporting
24 bit 96 kilohertz HD audio that means
you're getting enhanced connectivity
while using Bluetooth as well as clear
high resolution quality sound in a very
light and compact package that is pretty
impressive so I have the LG Tone free
T90 headphones now hooked up to my PC
and I'm about to play some games and
test this out what I really like about
these is they have built-in Dolby head
tracking so no matter what content
you're watching on what platform you'll
be able to experience the head tracking
feature so I'm watching a cut scene
right now on my game and so when I turn
my head
like from side to side it actually feels
like I'm a part of this cut scene like
I'm in the conversation so if I'm
turning this way and this way like you
can actually hear the difference is
pretty awesome okay so another thing
that is super cool about these
headphones is that they have a UV
nanotech built right into the case
basically it uses UV light to kill 99.9
of bacteria on the ear gels while the
earbuds are charging and plugged in so
when you're ready to put them in again
they're powered up clean and ready to go
I love that so they're now connected to
my TV and I really want to test out the
sound so I'm going to find myself an
Epic movie trailer and see what they
sound like I feel like trailers are
always a good test because the sound
design is always so good here we go
turning up the volume
oh yeah
this sounds like I'm sitting in a
massive theater with speakers all around
me this is where you can really tell the
Dolby Atmos kicks in because this is
like a movie trailer I feel like I'm in
the theater it's actually all around me
I thought I had a pretty decent sound
system in here but this is next level so
I want to see what this sounds like
watching a live show whoa they're
chanting his name it seems whoa
okay I'm gonna honestly enough and act
like I made this show now most normal
headphones don't really help much when
you watch live concerts at home so the
LG Tone free T90 headphones are an
incredible way to listen to Live
concerts from the comfort of my couch
the head tracking
is making it actually feel like I'm here
because it's keeping it whoa this is so
cool this is the comfiest concert I've
ever been to
testing these out on the big screen was
pretty incredible but honestly most of
the time I'm traveling I'm on the go I'm
not really watching TV that often so I
thought I would test this out in a
scenario that is most familiar to my
life I'm gonna watch something on my
tablet and in the headphones go and you
guys may be able to hear it that I am
pretty close to a road so there is a lot
of car noise so I'm going to turn on
active noise cancellation my movie has
started
and here we go the noise cancellation
definitely made a big difference
so turn it off
okay
turn it back on oh yeah it's a huge
difference sound quality is so important
and just watching this right here it
actually feels like I'm inside watching
on a large TV because it is so full and
filling and of course this head tracking
again makes it feel like you're in a
theater experience I think these are a
great option for people who don't like
over-the-ear headphones but yet you want
that Dolby Atmos sound these are small
compact and of course Very portable
overall the LG Tone free T90 wireless
earbuds seem like a pretty great option
for anyone looking for a comfortable
pair of earbuds with awesome battery
life and a fantastic listening
experience across a variety of devices
make sure you guys like this video and I
will see you guys in the comments and in
my next video bye